c'est devenu une tradition dans la ville
lumière
chaque année la plus grande avenue du
monde se pare de mille feux c'est comme
une pluie d'étoilés filantes
huit cent mille petites lumières de
technologie led accrochés aux 400 arbres
qui bordent l'allée des champs elysées
un spectacle de six heures du soir à 2
heures du matin qu'ils consomment
11000 kilowattheure mais pendant la
conférence sur le climat
l'impact énergétique est réduit presqu'à
zéro en majeure partie grâce à une
éolienne et à des panneaux solaires et
les passants sont une autre source
d'énergie
ils peuvent contribuer à la production
d'électricité sur les plates formes
d'activités le long des champs en
pédalant en marchant ou même en faisant
un brin de causette sur la balance on